thank you for soft for joining us this
afternoon today we're going to be
discussing a topic that affects the
teams that we work on how we interact on
those teams and whether we succeed and
also a topic that affects our consumers
and how they interact with our products
and even whether the extent to whether
they're able to experience our products
from I come from the machine learning
and AI world and I have witnessed facial
recognition apps that have not been able
to pick up on certain users because of
the color of their skins something that
could have been and that's because they
people like them weren't represented in
the data sets that were training the
products the algorithms that made the
product finally things that could be
easily fixed as the technology ecosystem
and Seattle thrive we have a
responsibility as technologists to be
mindful of our ever changing population
and world at large and so today we'll be
discussing ways that diversity can drive
better teams and better products so I'm
honored to have these panelists here and
I'm excited for them to share their
stories in this space and I'm going to
go ahead and let them introduce
themselves
we'll start with Ling hi everyone so my
name is Ling Chun I come from Metis
medicines of data science training
company and we provide you know a full
time immersive days training program as
well as part-time courses and corporate
core course corporate courses I am a
seen a data scientist at metas and I'm
also the data science book IV instructor
and yeah I'm like that to be here is my
first PI data
talking to my friends yesterday and I
was like trying to go to the bathroom
before like in contentment sorry I'm
doing tulips irises so let me tell this
thing but then I'll realize they're
actually lines at the men's bathroom
where there's no eyelet we don't process
why we're so thrilled right so quick oh
my god this never happens when I go out
to like theaters or meals and puzzles
over line and whatever happen and feels
like that's exactly the problem I was
like so that's a social right so um
thank you so much I'm still so great
that I can be on this panel we'll talk
about a lot of interesting things thank
you okay hi i'm andrea bryce and i'm
watching my own startup called busy
solutions and it's a company that's
meant to bring big data to small
businesses i come out of wireless
telecommunications I started with macaw
in 1989 when there was an analog system
and I was part of what was a consciously
inclusive hiring program I was the only
woman field tech in the US for quite
some time and there was no big data at
that time so I actually started
innovating pulling data from my network
elements to try to figure out where I
needed to go during the day to take
things and then the next thing you know
however many years later we're talking
to enterprise systems and ginormous data
sets and big data was out there in the
world so I had a career grow up around
it it was kind of cool
[Applause]
hi everyone I'm Charlotte Flanagan I'm
our global diversity of inclusion
diversity of inclusion lead at concur
over in Bellevue and a lot of people
including my dad continuously asked me
what does that mean and so essentially
what I do in the short short and sweet
version is really try to create programs
and policies that attract retain and
engage a really diverse set of employees
and beyond what we typically think of
diversity as well we're trying to really
expand on how we define diversity
and then also weave in how does
inclusion play it apart a role in that
and then also even beyond that what is
belonging look like as well so I'll
speak to some of that hi everyone I'm
Tina Maureen Kelly I am a marketing
leader and chick tech paddle director
Odyssey what I had up there I've been
working in tech for 10 plus years so I'm
a former King Korean I've worked at
startups and large companies and often
times I am either the only woman the
only person of color the only woman of
color so I'd ever see inclusion and
something that's you know very
passionate to me and it's tic tech
specifically and we really look to
empower women and girls to pursue
technology careers as you all know we're
always having conversations about you
know pipeline and ensuring that women
are giving a place at the table in terms
of leadership so we really tried to
provide a resource to women to do that
and then also the opportunities for
young girls to develop those resources
to learn what they want to do because
Tech is more than coding so we try to
really provide role models and education
to K through 12 girls hi everyone I'm
James I'm one of the volunteers here at
PI data Seattle in a semi-official
capacity I serve as an officer to the
board of num focus I serve as the vice
president in charge of or with the
purview over global PI data conferences
this is the second PI data conference
I've attended in two weeks so I can tell
you that initiatives like this diversity
panel are incredibly important to num
focus num focuses core mission is a
promotion of open source scientific
computing which requires that it exists
in a context of an open fair free and
diverse community
all right thank you all for introducing
yourselves and before we get started
I'll briefly introduce myself my name is
Dominique Davis I'm applied research
scientist at dimensional mechanics it's
an artificial intelligence startup just
down the road on 156 in the Bellevue
text center I am I have a cognitive
psychology background I trade and you
know by my previous research and I found
my way into the AI space I build AI
models for enterprise and we're building
a software platform for developers to
build AI models even if they're not um
you know experts in AI and ml so I enjoy
my job I also am a community engagement
lead for a bi Seattle which is for those
of you don't know it's the Seattle
chapter of Anita Borg Institute they as
you may know hosts the Grace Hopper
celebration of women in computing every
year international conference so and
just you know there's going to be a ght
one I'm going to do a shameless plug GHC
won mini Grace Hopper one day here in
November 11th Veterans Day okay so we
have that out of the way we're going to
go ahead and get started my first
question is for link what obstacles have
you encountered in building a diverse
community great so thanks thanks so much
that's an excellent question so what
difficulties are obstacles that I
encounter when building a community
there are many levels of this question
and know we can dive deep into it later
but on the surface there are two
components the first is building a
diversity a diversified community is not
always the first priority there so so
they're all going to the a bit later but
the second thing is even with the very
conscious intention to build
a diversified community it's simply just
really hard to find those diverse
candidate so understand a diversity is
not just you know I want to make sure
that that we all understand there is not
just one dimensional thing it's not just
you know gender is not just race is
really about background stability about
what you bring with the different
diversify skills right but let's take
general as an example like the exam I
was referring to before so as not as
we're trying to hire data scientists
we're trying to train data science but
throughout the whole pipeline is just
difficult it's just hard to find for
example female Canada female students
even the applications come in and we
don't have as many females okay so what
is the problem there why is this so hard
why are they just not there I think in
general it's because we are actually not
building this community from scratch we
already have a community there is
already the tech community through the
data science community there so we're
actually inherent a lot of buyers
inheriting a lot of the legacy from
before so what happens is that we're
trying to like were easily biased to try
to find people like us and people like
are encouraged to approach us and join
the community so that's one of the
things that I feel is really the
obstacle is the the role models or the
mentors that we have available for the
people that are interested in enjoying
this community especially for the
underrepresented groups like for example
women or or people of color so the the
thing is why is there not enough role
models because there aren't let's take
example of gender there aren't any women
so that other woman's feel intimidated
to approach and join this community and
then this community doesn't have any
more women so this is a vicious cycle
and it feels like there is nothing that
we can do thank you so much but I think
I would advocate just very conscious
efforts in building mentorship and
building and becoming role models and
sort of really propelling
other people's careers or people that
are actually junior of you propelling
their careers and supporting them as a
very conscious effort alright I want to
go back to the first point where I say
like a lot of times the diversity is not
the highest priority so I'm out of time
so let me just say this one thing we
built teams not all at once you will
build if I need 10 people on my team is
easy to find diversity but we're
building team members one at a time so
every time when I'm looking for that one
person there's a different priority
right so then when I'm doing one at a
time it's very easy to forget about the
other priorities thank you thank you
Ling and you brought up a great point
about diversity and the fact that it's
beyond gender and beyond race a lot of
people forget diversity of thought and
that's critical in teams that's
something to keep in mind you know
respecting others opinions and and ideas
and really championing those ideas
Andreea what lessons can you share about
overcoming these obstacles well in 1989
Wireless was a an industry that was a
Frankenstein mash of a variety of
technologies so there and there was also
nobody that had ever trained in wireless
telecommunications so they were really
responding to an environment that had no
precedent so they were looking for a
variety of skill sets they were looking
for a variety in their skill sets so
they were hiring people who had were
great at wiring but had no college
degree
they had took people out of the military
I was straight out of engineering school
in the lab and so it was more a matter
of trying to find people who were
adaptable and
excited about the questions that were
being asked in the business one of the
other things is that they really were
not concerned with the idea of like
trying to follow some sort of objective
measure of competency we had a lot of
people that washed out just simply
because the rate of change in wireless
telecommunications and the technology
rips were pretty merciless so competency
couldn't even be judged based on like
having had a successful career in one
industry and migrating into
telecommunications as a field tech we
did have some women that did apply for
jobs but when they interviewed with me
and I was telling them you're going to
be up on the middle of index driving up
a nodding Road in the middle of the
night with snow coming down and were 4th
and pike building on a Saturday night
you parking your truck out in the alley
and you're hauling your equipment up the
stairs how's that feel for you a lot of
women didn't want to do that to the
point where my director came and asked
me what are you scaring the women off
for I'm like I've just been sitting in
battery acid you can't you know so we
eventually did bring in more women that
were interested in that kind of of work
because it pays really well but the
point is is that they were freed at that
time from trying to say oh they have
this degree oh they can do that one of
the best engineers we ever took off took
with self-trained out of customer care
so what does it take to be good at your
type of work if you're looking for
people to repeat the answers back that
you're expecting then you're looking at
a job that sports replacing with a robot
so anyways thank you okay
so Tina actually yeah we're going to
skip a person Tina what actionable
advice do you have for someone who's
trying to increase understanding of the
value of building a diverse community
very good question I think one thing is
going beyond lip service a lot of us you
know will say oh yeah diversity
inclusion is really important but what
are you doing you know are you attending
events around diversity inclusion are
you following leaders around diversity
inclusion and going beyond global
leaders looking into your local area
seeing who are kind of the folks that
are speaking about it what can you learn
what are the insights that they have to
share that you can bring back to your
organization I think that's very
important also just showing up to groups
that don't look like you I think that's
number one you know we need the majority
to be a part of that so that means that
men need to show up for women and that
Caucasian people need to show up for
people of color abled people need to
show up for people that are disabled and
so on and so forth we all just need to
show up for each other
I think the other thing is understanding
what unconscious bias is and try to
understand you know the mechanics behind
it and and that's on every level from
you know somebody who's part of the team
to a hiring manager to folks that are on
leadership you know we all have it and
so the biggest way to kind of get past
it is to understand why you make those
decisions and try to train their brain
that to just be aware of those decisions
and I think the other thing is changing
diversity inclusion from an issue change
changing your mindset so it's a human
issue and a business issue right and not
just like Oh it'll be nice to just have
diversity inclusion you know we know
that more diverse teams build better
products you know they make better
business decisions and so
all around it's just diversity is a
better thing and so we all just need to
kind of change that mindset there and
then I would say the other thing would
be as we create job descriptions really
start analyzing those things you know
some of the things that we are putting
down than the list of must-haves are
really not must-haves you know and so
once we try it once we start to change
that kind of mindset we really try to
find the best candidate based off of
what they can do versus you know these
weird objectives that don't really mean
anything and I think the other the last
thing that I would say because I'm in
marketing is you know being able to
collect data you know when you have
interviews you know when you're looking
at who to promote you know really
analyzing the data so going beyond yes
we have 50 women that do this type of
job what's the technical element of
their jobs you know how many people are
in leadership and are we empowering
people so really looking at that data
analyzing it and holding yourself
accountable we all regardless of our
role need to help with diversity
inclusion and that was a great list of
actionable insights I hope you were
taking notes on that you know one thing
you talked about is immersing yourself
in an environment that you're not quite
used to that's that stands for all of us
you know at Tech inclusion a few weeks
back I used a gender-neutral bathroom at
the ED the same time that men were in
there for the first time and that was a
very eye-opening experience for me it
just you you know we all carry
assumptions and when you put yourself
you challenge yourself to put yourself
in that different environment it helps
you question and challenge those
assumptions all right
James have a question for you what
examples have you encountered where a
project was improved by having a
diversity so I'd actually like to hand
off this question to the chair of Pi
data Seattle Bret Canon as many of you
know Bret is a thing 15 or 16 years
cpython core contributor and as many of
you know the C Python core contribution
group has embarked for I think almost
two years now on a deliberate campaign
to cultivate and recruit a more diverse
set of cpython core contributors and I
think Bret might be able to speak very
specifically to why they've put so much
effort behind this Bret thank you for
putting me on the spot James yes James
said I've been a core contributor to
Python now since 2003
so 14 years and we actually got our
first female core contributor last
October I believe and we got our second
care willing from Jupiter I think is
known to some of you in the audience and
specifically what I found with having
Marietta and Carroll down on the team is
obviously a different viewpoint and also
a better focus in terms of trying to get
more people to join
obviously there's unconscious biases
it's been mentioned and obviously I'm I
suffer I'm sure we all do in some form
or another and so getting that first
person through the door was really
important to help have someone help off
balance any unconscious bias we may have
had on the core team because we all knew
we had a diversity problem and we tried
to solve the best we could obviously
because we didn't suffer from it was
hard to try to figure out exactly the
best mechanism to make that work and now
that we've pushed through the initial
problem gotten the first people through
the door we I first we found that both
Mary Ann and Carol have been really good
about trying to reach out on getting
more people to come in and help because
unfortunately they were in a minority
position and had to figure out how to
get more people engaged through PI
ladies and such and because of that
they're much better at actually engaging
with new contributors to the project and
that's helping get more people even more
involved so it's kind of led to a
somewhat of a cascading effect of
getting those first people through the
door to help with our diversity problem
too
getting more people involved and I'm
seeing more and more women actually
contributing now on github for Python
and just seeing a nice falter thank you
Brett for answering that you brought a
good point of that that first initial
just getting over that hump that's it's
critical and I mean it can be super
tough you know you don't want to have
those conversations or you're not sure
how to navigate to get you know have
those conversations and get past that
but once you do it's totally worth it
then you're able to see all of the
fruits of your Labor's so to speak
you're seeing you know a much more
diverse community of a thriving
community more ideas generated just a
good thing okay so this is - again -
James or Bret either one of you in the
wake of some high profile HR scandals in
tech should all be some remain nameless
how can we as a tech community build
more inclusive workplaces I think in
this question you allude to things like
such as the holder report in which we
see patterns of behavior that are so
egregious and so outside the bounds of
human decency so it's very difficult to
give an organization like that any
concrete advice other than stop or don't
I mean you should know that this
behavior is wrong and you should know
that treating people in your
organization in this fashion is wrong
and it's difficult for me to
intellectualize or moralize or
rationalize why it's wrong since it
seems so plain on its face what I would
say though is in many ways I think the
pie data community parallels the
industrial the experience I have in
industry because I come from front
office trading finance and the IT
surrounding that and while the front
office itself the traders themselves are
exactly the boys club that you might
imagine the i-tree group has always been
very professionalized it's very much a
nine-to-five job there really isn't that
much concern about somebody's gender or
ethnic background
it really is do your work go home you
know and spend time with your family
that said even in light of that you look
at a group where nobody seems to care
whether a programmer was female or male
what mystery they were and yet there
were no female senior managers and yet
there were three women in a team of 150
people so clearly even in even in the
lack of this egregious horrible behavior
there are still some serious systemic
biases at work that need to be
questioned and need to be investigated
and I think that much of the work that
we have to do is a lot more subtle than
what we see in the case of these
high-profile HR scandals where nobody
has to be told you know don't hit on
your subordinates that's wrong or if
somebody comes to you and they're
pitching to you and your VC don't tell
them you know I don't know whether or
not to ask you out to dinner or to fund
you I mean everybody knows it's just
that's just outside the bounds of what
you should do I think the real question
is what kind of unconscious or what kind
of hidden biases we have such that when
we look at the system structurally and
we don't see any outright forms of
discrimination somehow coincidentally
none of these systems seem to mirror the
actual populations that we have in
technology there there are abundance of
people and senior management roles that
just manage to to follow a very specific
pattern I think it then is a very much
an open question as to how do we
identify these biases and how do we
address them head-on
because I think that many of them are
really outside of what we can
immediately into it or see or tangibly
feel right now sure so I just want to
add something there's a really great
article out there it's I forget what
publication is from but it's basically
why silicon that it's called why Silicon
Valley is so horrible to women so I'm
sure a number of you have probably read
that Atlantic Monthly thank you and it
highlights different beyond just the
blatant sexual harassment that a lot of
women face in the workforce it goes
beyond that to even just in interviews
the things that candidates even will
completely dismiss talking to a female
VP
I mean there are very very interesting
examples of the way that inclusion or
lack thereof can show up in the
workplace and I would highly recommend
all of you to read it it is a lengthy
one but it's definitely worth it
so it's good that you picked up tonight
because this is you're up next
Charlotte what tips do you have for
diversity candidates when they're trying
to find a job um you know I was thinking
a lot about this and I don't I don't
know that my advice would be all that
different to anyone like I think my
advice is pretty much the same and it is
that if you are really interested in a
specific look at companies look at the
company where you want to be because
that culture what they stand for will
absolutely determine how long you're
going to be there and then if you find a
company that you love reach out to
people either who you know or either who
have a job title that's yours reach out
to them on LinkedIn and offer to buy um
coffee I had an intern who I met at
u-dub eight or nine years ago that
followed back up with me I to be honest
I barely even remembered her and she
finally like I was previously with
Alaska Airlines and she went to Alaska
and interned there and I didn't even
know that she ended up there I met her
at a career fair she just reached back
out to me because she's really
interested in coming to concur and I had
lunch with her I connected her with
someone who does the job that she wants
and that's the kind of relationships
that you can have and that you can build
that are so important and so I think
that would be my main advice is just
network like crazy and if you hear no or
you don't hear from people just don't
let it get you down keep going and keep
keep reaching out to people if you're
really interested in a certain company I
would add something to that as well I
think that's great and also when you are
building your network and you're
connecting with people just be
open-minded you never know down the road
how you might connect with that person
down the road so just yeah keep an open
mind one last point and I'm sure many of
you in this room know when it comes to
applying for jobs or
and thinking that you're eligible to
apply for a job I don't know if everyone
in this room is for the statistic but
it's something like 90 like women when
they apply for their job feel like they
need to meet 90% of the criteria that's
listed as required on a job description
whereas men it's more like 60 to 70
percent of the required stuff that's on
the Job Description
so my other piece of supposed to be like
don't limit yourself if you feel like oh
but it says three to five years I only
have two years just go for it like that
would be my other piece of advice too so
turn the table a bit
what what tips do you have for team
that's hiring and you know to avoid
hiring bias so there's actually a lot of
really cool technology that's out there
right now that I would definitely
recommend a couple companies ones local
it's called text EO so they work on job
descriptions and ensuring that the job
descriptions that you're posting or are
more inclusive and will attract a more
diverse candidate pool
there's also another company called
talent sonar that I am really really
hoping that will start using it concur
and they essentially help any
organization from job posting from
creating that job description but then
as follows and helps train your hiring
managers because that's where the bias
really creeps in is the team that's
doing the hiring and so how do you
create how do you remove the bias of
every single process from posting the
job to reviewing the candidates to
creating questions that actually tie
back to the job description not random
questions like what do you like to do do
you go skiing where you what college did
you go to it's more tying the questions
that you're going to ask and identifying
and setting the interviewers up for
success I love that Microsoft you have
to go through like a full-on course to
become an interviewer at Microsoft I
think that that is amazing because
unless you do that unless you're setting
the team up for success throughout the
hiring process
that's where biases are going to creep
in and there's a number of different
biases I think the biggest the biggest
offender I would say is the like me bias
when you have two candidates who are
exactly from more or less the same
Asians if you get along with someone
because they're a Seahawks fan or
because they like to go seeing on the
weekend you're going to build a natural
rapport with them way more and your
perception of them is going to be skewed
significantly and so ensuring that
you're sticking to structured questions
and questions that you ask the same
candidates all the same questions that's
how you can remove bias throughout the
hiring process you made a great note
about you know avoiding bias at every
level we think typically think of job
postings and then we think of the
interview process but really there are
multiple points at which so a candidate
can get you know scrapped because of
something that could have been avoided
you know and the idea of setting the
team up for or the applicant up for
success so thinking about how the
applicant can be included on the team
rather than that exclusion mindset it's
great okay Ling what advice do you have
regarding performance reviews or
promotions right so promotions oh my god
so actually there's an interesting story
I was just reading an article a couple
months ago
and it was a survey that actually looked
at salaries in I think the only did San
Francisco in New York so they were
looking at salaries in the tech industry
like software engineers designs and all
that and there was the saying that on
the entry level so on a very entry level
men and women are actually making
roughly the same it I think men still
make a tiny bit more of it but it's not
too much that they're mostly leveled and
as they both advanced in their careers
so when they look at the 3 to 5 years of
experience brackets they started to see
that men are actually making much more
than women so the author of the article
is like reasoning this as in oh when
you're you know fresh grad when you're
just entering the market you're actually
getting equal pay per women along their
careers are less likely to ask for
promotions so then after three to five
years
then you know men have a higher chances
of making more money because of
promotion right so I read this and I
says okay I was like oh it's reasonable
and you know this problem is easily
fixable we can just you know ask them or
like encourage women to you know speak
up a little bit more really you know
reach out and ask for promotions very
consciously right and then I am NOT can
you the same day on the same day in the
afternoon I read another article there
was another survey so it was also about
like sort of the same thing but they
were surveying Team Dynamics and the
server was saying like a man who asked
for promotions at our jobs are perceived
as you know positively because they're
really taking the stands they're they're
taking initiatives and women on the
contrary when they ask for promotions
among the team members they're actually
perceived more negatively because they
feel like they're asking for too much
they're like demanding too much and also
my god
like no way oh so so it's like I was
like oh this is good because there's a
problem that's easily fixable and
suddenly like this is not a win-win
series this is a lose-lose literature I
can't do anything right so if I don't
ask for most promotion I don't get
promotion for a promotion and perceived
more negatively as mortem ending so
there's no like I can't do it right
there's no way for me to do anything
right so I was really pissed off like
that so I think in the face of these are
conflicting yes thank you here in the
face of these conflicting sort of staff
what it really says is that we need to
more it's not about asking for promotion
it's really about you know a continuous
ongoing communication with your manager
about performance about promotion so
that you'll have to ask for promotion
only when you need or when you want a
promotion thank you so it should be a
constant check with where your career
goals are and communicate communicate
that to your manager so that you are on
the same page so then it's not too hard
to bring up the question when you really
want to promotion so what you're what
you've talked about is really about you
know transparency
between the employee and and and the the
manager and mentor and whatnot that way
it doesn't get bottled up and yeah
alright so let's see Tina what advice do
you have for managers to create a
trusting workplace that's a good
question
okay so I would definitely say the
leader needs to serve as a role model
again not just lip service actually you
know be transparent that was something
that you were saying so you know lots of
times as people that maybe aren't on the
leadership team you know we become
frustrated because we don't know what's
going on in the business and how
decisions are being made so it's always
good to you know make sure that that the
rest of the team is always kind of
involved or kind of knows what's going
on I would say that we really need to
make an effort to learn more about
people a lot of times we look at people
and we assume that we know about them
and we don't and especially when you're
working in those team dynamics it's
really important to do those team
outings although I know sometimes they
can be a little annoying but it's a it's
a good way to kind of set up rapport and
get to know the people that you work
with I would also say that when you are
listening to listen with an empathetic
ear I think a lot of times you know we
tend to think of our own issues and
don't necessarily take the time to
listen to other people I would also say
that a small question also just be aware
of yourself and kind of what you could
be doing the kind of to change the
outlook in your team within your group
to change that dynamic and also have I
always believe in having like great
feedback loops for everything that you
do so those two interviews whether
that'd be changing processes systems
just always like clearly communicate
those things and I think that's about it
all right I think we have time for one
more question quick question
Andreea what resources or social
networks do you use when you don't know
how to resolve a challenging workplace
question or situation or conflict
nevertheless she persisted sometimes
being the only in a group it's not just
lonely but their backs even studies that
show it directly affects performance I
was very lucky to have been hired in
Seattle I had I worked with the guys
that respected what I had to say would
joke with me respond to my ideas in a
positive manner who I could argue with
we talked about wrestling you know Tex
wrestling and like pigs in mud just
loving it without any negative
repercussions when I went outside of
market it was not that way
so it actually culminated one night
after a 24-hour shift and a retune that
was not good and some technology that
didn't operate as specified and so I
fixed did something that was not per
spec but made it work I had power where
I needed to have power and I went back
and I told the guys here's what you're
going to find at this location and
here's why I did what I did and here's
what you're going to see and they went
back and changed it all according to
spec so that meant that what was
radiating out at the antennas was
literally you know a fraction of the
amount of power that needed to you know
make it out of the system like why did
you do that
Hey and one person finally had the guts
to answer he's like we were these guys
weren't going to listen to you're a
woman okay it happens so but I was tired
and I was stressed and I was really
frustrated and I went back to Seattle
and I told my boss I said why am I even
here if I can't get the job do the job
well and have people listen to what I
have to say what's the point is that's
them that's not us and you're a good
tech and don't leave don't quit so I
mean it's moments like that where having
the team makes a difference in a
person's career and if you can be that
team mate to somebody who's the only
because there were no social networks I
mean yeah I'm old so I mean I read books
like women who run with wolves and a
simpler way but you know it was my
teammates that helped me make it through
and I worked with some of the most
amazing people in one of the most
amazing technologies in a technological
revolution so be a good teammate for
somebody who's a solo so I just want to
add really quick we we have the snack
period so the next talks not till 350 so
if you want a little more time you guys
have it Oh perfect okay I wanna say
Thank You Andrea for you know leaving us
on that high note I made a note earlier
to yeah be be a champion for someone
else if you you know hear an idea that
they may you know because inside you
don't know what's going on you don't
know whether they might be a little bit
shaky about it but they want to project
it to the team anyway say hey that's a
great idea
you know how can we take that further
how can we explore different options you
know that can I'm sure that person will
appreciate that and that will go far and
let's see
all right well yes that's always going
to do so I'd like to open it up to
everyone if you have a question for the
panel please have that taking runner
literally today so the title of this
panel is how diversity drives excellence
in our data-driven tech world but isn't
framing diversity in terms of its good
for your business rather than a social
justice issue make it extremely easy to
say well it doesn't seem to be doing all
that much for the bottom line so let's
throw less resources at it and isn't
that a lot of time what we see is it
marginalized I actually want to say
something about it because it's I
actually I generally believe like
diversity actually drives this drives
excellence for the whole business
including the bottom line so I want to
make an analogy I mean we're at pie data
so like we have a lot of you know people
wrangling with data data scientist so
there's something in machine learning
world called ensemble models right so so
for example take a simple example we
have random fours or maybe we have
stacking classifier let's say I want to
do this classification right I want to
stack three classifiers together would
you would you have three classifiers
that are logistic regressions such as
regression and logistic regression and
stack them together I mean it's not
going to work right so when you want to
do ensemble methods you will stack a
tree model a logistic regression maybe a
Bayesian model and then and then
collectively they do a much better job
at predicting whatever like conversion
rate err adds like whatever you want to
do right so why does why does it happen
that way because each model have a
different underlining assumption that's
this to a certain pattern within the
data so when you have one model you're
actually making some underlining
assumptions and if the data doesn't
really fit this kind of assumption or
maybe the data was generated from a
different process this one model is not
going to work it's the same thing with
people like we're all people with that's
why diversity in background and
diversity in skills so this is just as
important as you know
or all the other things that we talked
about explicitly we need people that
don't think all the same thing if we're
all like full full of people in a room
but we all think alike like what's the
point of having like all the people like
just uttering the same cells right so
it's both you have to speak to it from
both aspects of it you have to have the
business case diversity and you have to
have the the it's the right thing to do
and if if leaders aren't speaking to
that I mean you could Google business
case for diversity and you can see
literally hundreds of studies that have
been done about the impact that the
diversity has on the bottom line on
productivity on employee engagement on
turnover on a number of different
statistics and in my opinion to ignore
that is pure ignorance so that would be
my response the other response is that
you have to have you have to take that
data to leadership and you have to get
their buy-in at whatever company that
you work in because they're the ones
that are providing the resources to the
diversity and inclusion initiative so my
question was for those of us who have
been like solos how you deal with what
are practical steps that you've done to
deal with impostor syndrome even at your
job or like you know constantly doubting
that you're good enough even though you
are I take this one because I just went
through this so I am new to concur I've
only been here then with concur for
about a year and I went to my sister
who's 10 years older than me
and I said you know this this job feels
a lot bigger than I think I'm really
ready for and she said she told me a
story and I'm probably totally going to
mess it up but Jen Mueller is a local
sports broadcaster or my broadcaster I
think like journalism maybe and she
talks about this story when she
interviewed an apologies for using
sports analogies but she interviewed a
assistant head coach for a college or
university and someone like the head guy
head coach left or something and she was
like so you know are you going to be
taking on the head coach role and he
said no she said so you tell me if
so-and-so didn't come to you and said I
want you to be the head coach then you
would turn it down he said no I take it
he's like we just said you weren't ready
for it
he said if they think I'm ready for it
that I'm ready for it so if you're if
you're going through something and
you're having self-doubt my biggest
piece of advice is to reach out to
someone reach out to your network and
talk through it for sure and just
honestly believe that you can and
there's a great TED talk about the power
posing and I swear it works so do that
before interviews I did in the concur
elevator up to my final interview and
I'm not ashamed to share that and I like
to add because I I mean I've worked with
more technology rips and having to start
over everything I knew was gone we just
ripped you know one vendor to a next you
know one you know and CDMA to GSM bah
blah blah blah blah you're always
starting over when you just start
getting used to like not knowing and
okay you start developing the skills of
jumping in and not knowing anything and
being and starting over again and once
you've done it a couple of times
honestly it gets boring so there's
something called the donor Colossus
syndrome in psychology so what happens
is when people are giving tests so the
people that actually score lower on the
tests overestimated themselves much more
than people at that actually scored
higher on the test field so so if you're
actually pretty good you will
underestimate yourself that oh I'm not
that good but if you really don't know
nothing about it you're like oh yeah I
totally do it
to have impostor syndrome is number one
just means you're human and number two
problem means that you are actually more
self-aware and under estimating yourself
which means in turn you might be
actually well above on the on the curve
so that might be other thing can I ask
you a question how many men in this room
have ever heard that term impostor
syndrome and how many women pretty even
interesting
I've got a question I heard you talking
about the importance of person number
one and I realized with shocking
self-doubt oh my gosh I have just
stepped away from being person number
one on a team I'd looked at teams and
said oh my god I'd be the only woman
they probably won't listen to me and
I've had all this talk of like oh they
won't listen to me I'll have a hard time
getting hurt in meetings and so I've
always been person number two and so now
I'm wondering like maybe there's
something we could do to try to like
encourage people to be person number one
yeah okay
having been person number one all I can
say is I like to so at this point in my
career I try to spend a lot of time
mentoring younger women and one of the
biggest things I find is just getting
them to speak up speak out and speak
loudly and so what if you make a mistake
who cares we're the ones who say
apologize guys don't go around
apologizing but we will and you know
what that's okay but that's actually one
of the things that we bring is a
positive thing so I don't know I mean
fear of failure fear of making a fool of
yourself fear of fear of fear of you
know if you're not walking towards your
fears then I don't know to me that that
that says to me that again it's like
having all the answers already it gets
boring so I'd say if you're a frightened
be don't know what the heck you're doing
and see at least trying to take a chance
and that's where you're growing yeah I
always say you should make yourself so
uncomfortable you never want to just be
stagnant and then ask when you can bring
another one on the team and just so just
that there's also it's just two sides of
this right there's the person who's
going to be the first person to join a
group and then there's also people who
are already in the group welcome the
person in so there's two sides to it and
it really can make a difference I kind
of have this turn of phrase where I say
you can't just open the door you hope
you have to welcome people through it
so it really does come down to whether
or not you're going to be going into
situation where you feel like the group
is going to be welcoming you in as
knowing full-well
all right you are the first woman first
minority first whatever and they're
welcoming to that understand that and
can at least try to address their
unconscious bias that they probably have
because I mean honestly we all have it
whether we want to admit it or not I
mean I will admit I have it we all do
the best we can to minimize it but it's
there so at least if they're willing to
admit to it have you come in and tried
to say all right we're going to work on
trying to deal with it that helps a lot
as well to make it a much more welcoming
environment for the person who's going
to be the first person through the door
are there any more question we can we
can do one more but we just have to keep
it short I'm like if there's still three
and a half minutes we can we can make it
look like work for me so any thoughts
from you guys on basically the so
retaining and attracting folks that you
know are experiencing the unconscious
bias and stuff like that but also making
it welcoming for those who want to
support that effort if that makes sense
so I've been a solo as well and I've
been welcomed onto my team but that's
because those folks were you know like
given permission to do so if that makes
sense you know like it was okay to do it
so how do we foster that sorry I'm
really nervous I don't know why I think
the biggest thing here is when we see
that it needs to be done and there's not
a group or thing that's already built to
build it so that means going to your
manager going to HR and saying hey these
you know they're there's a group of
people that are having some issues like
I'd like to create a program that really
Foster's relationship so we can help
them be happy at their job and not and
provide support for these people so
whether it be you know people of color
people women anyone else in the spectrum
of diversity because we know it's so
many things just creating those
processes where they feel supported
and groups where they can kind of talk
about things together you know just
share their their shared experiences
it's I think it's easier and some of the
larger groups you know they a lot of
them do have ERG s but I think the cool
thing about smaller companies and
startups is that they're able to be more
nimble and created really fast and kind
of learn as they do it I think you
alejandra actually could probably speak
to some things that she's done if you
want to catch her offline you know she's
a great example of what she's done at
cdk global in terms of fostering that
environment for for women and women of
color - right well I personally want to
thank all of you I have a wife and tech
who works as a lead at a development
company we spend a lot of nights talking
about this and thank you so much for
sharing with us but it's what it's like
to experience this and how to get over
the stuff let's all give a round of
applause
[Applause]